[موسيقى]
ام
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم تقل الامم
المتحده على حق عندما شبهت الماساه
السوريه بماساه رواندا
اليست ماساه تسونامي والصومال خمس نجوم
مقارنه ب ماساه الشعب السوري
الم يصبح رغيف الخبز يحل من بالنسبه
للكثير من السوريين الم تصبح كل السلع
اليوميه البسيطه خارج متناول المواطن
السوري بعد ان جنت اسعارها الم تصبح
الليره السوريه برخص التراب مقابل العملات
الصعبه
لماذا تدفع الحكومه السوريه رواتب الشعب
بليره ثم تبعهم كل شيء بالدولار حتى البصر
الا يواجه الثلاثاء الشعب السوري خطر
المجاعه حسب الامم المتحده اليست سوريه
مقبله على ثوره جياع عارمه بالاضافه الى
ثورتها من اجل الحريه والكرامه
عجبا لمن لا يجد قوت يومه كيف لا يخرج
شاهرا سيفه يتساءل الجياع السوريون
لكن في المقابل الا يبقى الاقتصاد السوري
صامدا بالنظر الى الخراب الذي حلب سوريا
الا تبقى العمله السوريه مستقره لو
قارناها بعملات البلدان التي مرت بظروف
مشابها كالعراق ولبنان
ليس الشعب السوري معتادا على الازمات
والحصار اليس هناك الكثير من الدول الذي
او التي تدعم الاقتصاد السوريه ايران
وروسيا والعراق والصين لم تحصل سوريا قبل
ايام على قرض بقيمه اربعه مليارات دولار
من روسيا اليس الغلاء معقولا في سوريا
مقارنه بالمؤامره الكونيه التى تتعرض لها
البلاد
اليس الشعب السوري قادرا على تحمل تبعات
الازمه والانتصار عليها اليست ثوره الجياع
التي يبشر بها البعض في سوريا مجرده
تمنيات تامريه اسئله اطرحها على الهواء
مباشره على الناشط والباحث السوري السيد
هيثم سباهي وعلى الاعلام السوريه المعارض
السيد ابراهيم نبدا النقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تشهد او ستشهد سوريا ثوره جياع
ا جديده بسبب الوضع الاقتصادي الخطير صوت
على صفحه الاتجاه المعاكس حوالي تسعه عشر
الفا ثمانيه وسبعون فاصله ثمانيه نعم واحد
وعشرين فاصله اثنين لا لو بدات بهذه
النتيجه معك سيد ابراهيم يعني ما الذي
يجعل هذه النسبه الكبيره ثمانيه وسبعون
بالمائه يعتقدون بان سوريا بالاضافه الى
ثوره الحريه التي تقوم بها الان مقبله على
ثوره جياع
لانه اذا حاولت ان تنظر الى الوضع
الاقتصادي الحالي وليس وفق ما قالته الامم
المتحده ان سوف اعتمد في في تحليل هذا
الوضع على ارقام النظام نفسه حتى لا
يقولوا ان هذه الارقام المعارضه او يقول
الهيئه الان مؤامره كونيه ارقام النظام و
تكفي لاننا دخلنا في مجال يعني عندما تنظر
الى قطاع الزراعه ال القطاع الزراعي موجود
في الارياف الارياف اكثر من نصف الشعب
السوري الارياف اغلبها تم حرق حصلها من
قبل النظام او تم تدمير البنيه التحتيه من
من اه اه اقنيه للراي تم اصبح الشعب هناك
غير قاتل عن العمل لا يوجد حتى ينتج لا
يوجد شيء حتى ياكل نفسه فما بالك حتى يطعم
المدن يعني اصبحت المدن التي كانت تعتمد
على الزراعه لتعيش منها تحصل عليها على ال
ال السلع لم تحصل على هذه السلع والذين
يعملون في هذا الموضوع لم يعد لديهم دخل
الحمله بامكانهم لان يستوردوا من الخارج
ولم يحصل حتى اذا ارادوا ان يزرعوا على
مواد على السماد على ال على اي مواد
مبيدات للحشرات اي وسائل للوسائل الزراعه
غير ممكنه وان تبقى بعض المناطق السيطره
عليها النظام يستخدمها الى مراكز عسكريه
يضع فيها دباباته واسلحته تحت الاشجار وفي
الحقول ويسيطر عليها ويترك بعض الحقول
البعض منهم
بعض بعض الاشياء هذا من ناحيه الزراعه اي
ان الزراعه كاحد القطاعات الاساسيه في وضع
انهيار اذا تحدثنا عن وضع الصناعه التي هي
تعتبر من القطاعات الاساسيه ايضا اين هي
المناطق الصناعيه في حلب ويرى فيها في ريف
دمشق في ريف حمص في بعض المناطق الاخرى كل
هذه المناطق تعرضت الى تدمير البنيه
التحتيه يعني حتى اذا نظرت على الارقام
التي تتحدث عنها اه مؤسسات النظام واعلام
النظام يقولون لك افقه عشره بالمائه من
المؤسسات الصناعيه هي التي فقط لا زالت
تعمل تسعين بالمائه من المؤسسات لا تعمل
انك تتحدث عن عن دوله اذا سمى الدوله في
هذا الوضع قطاع الزراعي فيها صفر قطاع
صناعي
في في في الحديث وفي وفي المحصله ونتيجه
كلا الحالتين هناك حاله مخيفه اطاله
تتراوح ب حوالي سبعين بالمائه حسب ايضا
الاعلام النظام الذي دائما يردد ان هناك
لا يوجد لا يوجد اي اي فرص للبقاء يعني
اذا نظرت الى غرفه غرفه بالاضافه اضف الى
ذلك يعني
الزراعه انتهت والصناعه انتهت يبقى
التجاره من المفترض ان يكون التجار عليهم
دون ان يستورد وا ما يعجز عنه الوطن من
انتاجه او من صناعه او زراعه يقولون لك
حسن غرفه صناعه دمشق يقول وانت سبعين
بالمائه من رجال الاعمال في سوريا هاي
وفقه الفين واثنين الفين وثلاثه وسبعين في
المائه سبعين بالمائه من رجال الاعمال
اصبحوا خارج البلاد بال 2012 فاذا انتهى
اخذت كل ها النقاط وشهدت ايضا تصريحات من
بعض رجال الاعمال لازاله لازالوا تحت
سيطره النظام يعني مثلا احمد ان احد
مستوردي السائل يقول لك ان التجار الذين
في سوريا و يتاجرون في هذه المرحله اصبح
متر ب حين من الحرب يعني هادول كانوا زمان
نتحول الان الى تجار وامراء حرب يتاجرون
يعني بدماء الشعب اثناء السلم والان يجري
اخر قطره الدماء موجوده لدى الشعب واخر اه
ما الموجوده بيد الشعوب يسحبونها من
جيوبهم حتى في لحظه لحظه جميل جدا اذن على
المستوى الزراعي على المستوى الصناعي على
المستوى التجاري على مستوى كل شيء انهيار
كامل و اضف اليها لناخذ هذه النقطه نقطه
سيدفع
اولا بالنسبه
ثوره الجياع لن يكون ثوره الجياع في سوريا
سوريا بخير والشعب السوري قادر ان ي يعني
يجتاز هذه المرحله هناك انسان حرب في
سوريا والحرب تتطلب
والاقتصاديه كل شيء ان خفت في الحروب حتى
الانتاجيه يعني دعني اقول لك شيء اه هناك
مشكله
ولاحظناها من فتره مشكله انا تكلمت مع شخص
حلبي اليوم في مدينه حلب قال المعارضه
والجيش الحر يريدون
الحلبيين لكن الحلم
ممكن تشرح لي يعني لو اعطيت هذه
المعدات هذه المعدات التي خرجت من معامل
حلب
عبر الحدود التركيه
من الجيش الحر والجماعات المسلحه
بدون
بدون شهادات بدون فواتير تخرج الى دوله
ثانيه هل تستطيع ان تاتي بمعدل وترسلها
الى اي دوله بدون اوراق
لم تقدم
الجواب ال ال ال الموجوده هناك هذا خيط من
خيوط المؤامرات عندما تفكك المعامل اكثر
من
موضوع
فكره لا احد يشك بانه
خلينا نتفق مع كانه هناك مؤامره وانه
المصانع
السؤال المطروح
هذا يؤكد كلام بانه البلد انهار وانه
القادمه
دكتور لا يستطيع
اقتصادي ان يتنبا بما يحدث بعد اسبوعين
عندك السيد
تنبا فيها اربعه وعشرين ثمانيه
الفين وثمانيه ان الدولار الدولار في حاله
موت سريري
واستعدوا لدفنه كيف ت تنبه عن الدولار يا
سيدي
لكن الاقتصاديين لا يتنبهون هناك حر في
سوريا والدوله في سوريا تتعامل معها عندما
وصل الدولار منذ اسبوعين الى ارقام معينه
طبعا هناك تجار
اذا رجعوا دولار الشعب السوري حماس
الشريحه واذا
الشعب السوري
جمعيات خيريه صحيحه كمان
هذا الكلام الرجل يقول لك
كلها من خلال المناطق التي هي تحت سيرت
ارتكب بعد وها بالرخيص شبيحتكم قدموا
فواتير وباعوها لمن يهربون وقاموا
[ضحك]
بالنسبه لما يقول عن الساحه خفض الدولار
يعني اقول لك لعبه الدولار على المكشوف
الدولارسعر الدولار ليس لديها سعر
المضاربه بيع وشراء والسعر الحقيقي سعر
السلعه
يفترض ان السلعه سعرها دولار في سوريا
يعني بما يعادل سابقا كان ثلاثمائه وخمسين
ليره سعر الدولار يعني الساعه سعر السلعه
كانت مائه وخمسين ليره انتو عم بتقولوا
نزلت دولاب لمائه وخمسه وسبعين بالمائه
لماذا لماذا الى هذه اللحظه لم تنزل اسعار
السلع اقول لك ماذا عن الغلاء اذا اقول لك
ماذا فعلت
شركات السياحه كلها تتبع رامي مخلوف قاموا
برفع
سحبوا الاموال الليره السوريه سعر الدولار
الدولار بثلاث مائه وخمسين ليره سوريه من
المواطنين بعد ان حصلوا على هذه الاموال
الليره السوريه ذهبوا وباعوها الى البنك
المركزي
خمسه وسبعين
شركات الصراع في جماعه السبعين الحرام
الذين يتاجرون بشركات شركات ال المال
ثرواتهم خلال اقل من اسبوع
وترك الشعب الذي دعونا انه يدعمونه يحصل
الطبقه المتوسطه خسرت خلال الاسبوع
ثرواتها نتيجه هذه الهزه ومع ذلك بالرغم
انه لا زال المقبلين على السنه الدولار
لانهم يعلمون بالضبط سعر الدولار يعادل
خمسمائه ليره سوريه وليس ثلاثمائه وخمسين
لانه
دليل اخر وهي من المحللين وهي من المحللين
كم هذا احمد صبيحه النظام المتابعين نظام
يقول بالحرف الواحد لو ان الدوله مهتمه
بالشعب السوري مائه مليون يورو التي
دفعتها لتخفيض الى الدولار كان بامكانها
ان تستورد على المواطنين كان بامكانها ان
تستخدم هذه المليارات لتمويل الاستيراد
المواطن عندما يريد ان
يدفع خمسمائه ليره سوريه على الدولار
دولار الاستيراد خمسمائه
امام الدولار الشعبيه وخمسه وسبعين
الدولار
انه الدوله لا تقدم التي يسمونها دوله
هؤلاء اصبحوا تجار يتاجرون على حساب الناس
لا يقدمون
ان اوضح لك من المستفيد من كل هذه الحرب
باختصار هذه المضاربه هي تحاول ان تمول
شركات الصراف التي هي تمول س بيحتكم لان
النظام لم يعد لديهم ما ورد اخر غير
المضاربه على حتى تحول عقليه
يرسلون حتى على الشعب من اجل ان يدلون هم
من الطبقه المتوسطه التي هي عمود عموم وهي
الهيكل العظمي للاقتصاد التي ت تعمل فقيره
وتقول الغني الطبقه المتوسطه تم افكار
بهذه المضاربات كل ذلك من اجل ان يبقى
اسلحتهم يتحركون اذا نظرت الى قضيه اه
خلينا خلينا ناخذ
الحقيقه المطلقه بس اسالك سؤال انت تعلم
ان الموظف السوري اه كان يحصل على عشرين
الف ليره سوري ما يسمونه الملك عشرين الف
ليره سوري يعني ما يعادل 4
يعني ما يعادل اربعمائه دولار امريكي
البعض يقول في واقع الامر ان انخفاض سعر
الليره السوريه مقابل الدولار هو في صالح
النظام لانه في الماضي كان يعطي مقابل
العشرين الف ليره سوري اللي هي الراتب
اربعمائه دولار الان مع انخفاض سعر الليره
السوريه اصبح راتب الموظف السوري مائه
دولار لا غير يعني النظام هو المستفيد او
الحكومه السوريه هي المستفيده في الوقت
الذي الرواتب بقيت على حالها اصبح كل شيء
في سوريا يباع بالدولار
دولار يعني
كمان
المطروح كيف تبيع للمواطن السوري حتى
البصل والبقدونس والفشل بسعر الدولار وما
سمته تعطيها الراتب الليره السوريه اليس
هذا احتيال ا ونسبي على المواطن السوري
الضغوط على الاقتصاد السوري هناك ضغوط على
الدوله في سوريا هؤلاء من قومه من عام
الفين واحد عشر
ويقولون ستسقط الدوله ونريد على سوريا
قلنا لهم ان
العقوبات ستؤدي الشعب السوري
معارضو موالي ست وزي وهذا الكلام تكلمنا
فيه كثيرا على برنامجها كانت تكلم فيه
العقوبات تؤذي هل هناك من معارض طلب من
دوله اوروبيه غير السلاح هل طلب رفع
الاخوان السوريين او لا السوريين عندهم
لكن دعني اقول لك كما قال
او قريبي من دمشق اليوم ان احسن ما في هذه
الازمه الاقتصاديه هي ترابط العائلات
والسوريين مع بعضهم نحن نحن من جوع ولا
بلادنا بها خير ترابط العالم
الامم المتحده
هذه ليست اه التنبؤ معلومه في 22 1 2012
انتهت الحكومه السوريه الحكومه السوريه
الدوله السوريه موجودين معلومه خليني
اعطيك هناك ستمائه وخمسين طالب سوري في
بريطانيا لا قبل شهرين مائه وخمسين الف
استرليني بمعدل الف واربعمائه استرليني
شهريا لا يستطيعون تحويل المال الى هنا
ومعظم وهو متى ومعظم ومن قسم منهم معارض
عندما قال
عندما قال احد الاشخاص
الدكتور سامي الخيمي انه بهم معارضين
الدكتور سامي الخيمي قال المعارض والمؤيد
الدراسه
خليني هذه النقطه بس دقيقه طيب كيف عندما
الامم المتحده لديها ارقام ولديها الفرق
على الارض ولديها معلومات واحصائيات
تقول له انه الازمه في سوريا لم تعد تقارن
لا بافغانستان ولا بالعراق ولا بالصومال
ثلثي الشعب السوري مقبل على مجاعه مقبل
على مجاعه ماذا تقول له يا اخي نحن في
سوريا اراضينا صراعيه موجود حدودنا موجوده
موجوده شبكات الطرق موجوده اذا لم تحل هذه
الازمه بعمليه سياسيه يستطيع اصلاح الدوله
تستطيع
[تصفيق]
الشعب السوري شعب بدا البنى التحتيه
الانتاج الزراعي موجوده في سوريا والاتفاق
ونحن نعرف جميعا ان هناك كان اكتفاء ذاتي
في
طيب هذا الكلام انتم ترون والبعض يقول انه
سوريا مقبله على ثوره جياع سوريا مقبله
على كذا السوريون جوعا السوريون كذا
السوريون كذا يقول لك يا اخي كل هذا
الكلام عباره عن تمنيات تامريه بالدرجه
الاولى لو كان هناك جياع فعلا في سوريا
انتفضوا ليس هناك مجاعه سوريا تعاني لانها
في وضع حرب ماساه حقيقيه
في اللحظه التي يخرج فيها من هذه الازمه
كيف ترد على هذا الكلام يا سيدي بالنسبه
ليس
باداب الحديث الصراع يوم عندما تحدثنا عن
الى اي مرحله وصف هذا النظام النظام
الصناعيه في طرطوس وهذا الكلام عن جديده
مدير مدير منطقه المنطقه الحره
الجوع يا اخي اعطيني امثله قبل ما تحكي لي
الموضوع الانسان يا اخي انا
يعطيني اركان الموضوع بدون ما تعمل
واقتصاد عامل اعطيني اعطيني
اعطيك
هاي من مواقع النظام معظم السوريين يعيشون
حاله ام لا
الفقره المطلق يعني الموت حتى الفقر
موقعكم واقع النظام
عمله احصائيه يقولون بالحرف الواحد ان
الاسره حتى تستطيع ان تعيش دون الظروف
الحاليه تحتاج اربعه وخمسين الف ليره
سوريه حتى تعيش
تاخذ هي في الاصل هو يقولون ان اه حصلت
وسط هذا المبلغ سوف تكون في فقر
الم الذي حظي جيد يحصل اثنين وعشرين حسب
متوسط اصول العاملين الذين يحصلون على
رواتب اثنين وعشرين مع العلم ان حوالي
سبعين بالمائه في حاله يعني انت تتكلم عن
فقط عشرين بالمائه يحصلون على هذه الرواتب
التي هي بالاصل دون خط الفقر
حساباتكم ارقامكم في ظل هذا الوضع وفي ظل
ايضا عندما تنظر ايضا الى حجم الدمار الذي
يقود ان البنيه التحتيه اذا توقفت الحرب
عادت الامور يعني زراعيه وغير الزراعيه
سوف اتحدث عن البنيه
مختلف
شقها ال عمران وسطها الزراعي والصناعي
والبنيه التحتيه تكون
ارقام يكون تقول انها وصلت ثمانين مليار
دولار
وهذا الارقام ايضا في بدايه العام ثمانين
مليار دولار حسب
دمار هذه البنى التحتيه سوف امثال هو
يحبونه كثيرا جماعه النظام وهي العراق
العراق بعد عشر سنوات من توقف الحرب
وسيطره نظام جديد عليها حسم الدمار في
البنيه التحتيه في العراق
اقل من حجم الدمار الذي حصل في سوريا مع
ذلك
امكانات العراق نفط العراق
النفط النظام السوري اضف الى ذلك ان
العراق كل دول العالم جاءت ل تساعده
العراق الجديد حتى بما فيه ايران وامريكا
الذين يدعون الخصوم اجتمعوا في هذا البلد
ومع ذلك عشر سنوات الاقتصاد لازالت العراق
تحت الفقر
تعتبر بغداد اوسع مدينه في العالم لا يوجد
خدمات هل هؤلاء لم
يستطيعوا ان يكون ذلك ولنفترض ان بشار
الاسد مع ثوره الحريه والكرامه اقل مما
اعتبره مع الثوره المسلحه واراد الان ان
يواجه هذا الخراب الذي يعني رفعوا شعار
بالبلد
كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا الوضع
الى ثوره الحريه والكرامه والثوره المسلحه
هذه اذا نظرت ايضا الى موضوع قضيه المدنيه
الاب يقول ان حل البنيه التحتيه عندهم
اصدقائها يقول لك عند ايران وعندهم روسيا
بيحصلوا على
رؤوسنا قبل الثوره انه لا
سوريا
هذا قدري جميل جماعه انه بالشهر من ايران
خمسمائه مليون دولار من ايران
ايران من ايران
التشريع
نعم نعم نعم
بالاضافه الى ذلك
الاعلام الايراني يقول لك قدموا سبعه
مليارات
نعم
اسمع اسمع
لنفترض انهم حصلوا بمعدل ايران بين عشرين
ثلاثين مليار من بدايه الازمه كم الى هذه
اللحظه ثلاثين مليار هذه المليارات
استخدمت
الان سوف تمت كم يوم من الايام الازمه سوف
تنتهي بشكل من الاشكال لتسويه تسويه
اقليميه او دوليه ايران التي استثمرت فيكم
سوف تبحث عن مصالحها اذا حدثت صفقه
اقليميه بين دول الخليج وايران سوف يقوم
سماه للبيع هو التي
[ضحك]
الى ذلك
باختصار يعتقد ان صديقه لهم مكانه ايران
تريد ان تقدم لكم شيئا او للشعب السوري
كما يدعون اين كانت اربعين سنه ليست هي
صديقه للنظام الاسدي اربعين سنه ما تقدمت
الاربعين
ايران لها علاقات استراتيجيه صديقه مو
صديقه يحكومه
الايراني طيب يعني كيف تريد من الشعب
السوري ان يعول على ايران عندما يعلم ان
اكثر من خمسين بالمائه من الشعب الايراني
يعيش تحت خط الفقر
يعني يعني مثل شو بدي اقول لك المتعوس على
خايب الرجا يعني اللي عم يراهن على ايران
يعني على من تراهنون السؤال الاخر الشعب
السوري لم
هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان
فيما لو انتصر النظام غدا فيما لو استقرت
الامور غدا الشعب السوري سيبقى محاصرا
لعشرات السنين من العرب وغير العرب
الناس اللي عندها فلوس الناس اللي عندهم
لماذا تريد ان تضحي ب شعب كامل لعشرات
السنين يعني الشعب السوري يجب ان يعلم
الان في كل الاحوال سيعاني لعشرات السنين
اقتصاديا فل يعني بالشعب السوري
عندما اتحدث مع السوريين الان يقول لك
الان حتى الخبز اصبح حلما بالنسبه للشعب
يا سيدي يا سيدي الانسان عندما يحصل على
خبزه في سوريا الان يحقق انجاز كبير يخرج
المواطن السوري يشترك اليوم بندوره وشويه
خاص الف ليره
بعض السوريين حتى اللي مع النظام حتى مع
النظام ماذا يقولون يقولون صبرنا على
القصف صبرنا على القتل صبرنا على الدمار
الان لم يبقى لدينا من قله يراجع لم يبقى
لدينا بان قله من يبقى الشعب السوري الشعب
السوري يواجهون
هذا نحنا
كلام
الموالين والمعارضين
بسوريا عرف تماما انهم تعرضوا
المؤامره
قطر
المشفى الميداني في شفاء اه
شمال العزيز لانها صاحبه فلوسه هذا
التحريض
والكلام اللي كان
والناس الاستفاده
ومعارض يعرف جميعا انه تعرضوا
وعليهم اذا انت عايش ببلد ابريطانيا
الشعب البريطاني بقي على البنا من عام
تسعمائه وخمسه واربعين عام الف وتسعمائه
وخمسه وستين لم يتذمر عندما تتعرض لها لكن
نحنا ما يحز في انفسنا ان هم سوريون
عرضوا على الحرب
الدكتور
اللي الناس اللي تيجي تدفع اما اذا اذا
اذا
اما اذا في الناس الناس فيها هذه
اول مره اسمع فيها
الدولارات
الموضوع
السوريين اللي موجودين في في في
مخيمات اللاجئين اللي موجود هذه مسؤوليه
[تصفيق]
الثمانينات كان عنه وضع صعب كثير ما قاموا
به الاخوان المسلمين اه اه
هذا الموضوع
يقول لك الرجل الشعب السوري تعود على
الحصار
والكثيرون يعني كيف ترد عليها عندما يقول
انه لماذا نلقي باللائمه على النظام اذا
كان هناك حصار خانق من الاقربين والابعدين
على الشعب السوري الشعب السوري انت تقول
للعراق تقول العراق الشعب السوري قادر على
اعاده بناء سوريا والعوده بها الى مصاف
الدول المتقدمه
بوقت قياسي
الشعب السوري لا احد يشك امكاناته الجباره
المشكله هي ليست بالمعارضه والنظام
المشكله هي بين من يقتلون الشعب السوري
[ضحك]
يا سيدي تعلم اننا اليوم نحن في اقتصاد
العقليه الدوله اليوم ما تسمى دوله تتصرف
وسوف
معلومات تتحدث في الداخل جوازات السفر في
سوريا هناك سوداء
يعطوك جواز سفر بالطريقه السوق ماذا فعلت
الدوله لو كانت دوله لو كان الدوله وشعبها
تحتاج لتخرج للوضع اللي واسباب امنيه
كانت من المفترض ان ت ان تقدم لهم جوازات
السفر
تتحسن الامور ماذا حدث
هناك العقليه الشيطانيه لدى هذا النظام
حتى السوق السوداء نفسها فاصدر قرار
باصدار شيء اسمه الجواز المستعجل يعني
بدنا ان تتصل السوق السوداء خمسطاشر
لجماعه النظام يعني حتى
قضيه تهريب الذهب يعني
رئيس جمعيه الصاغه في دمشق يقول طلبه من
الدوله ان تسمح له باعاده
الذهب
النساء بسبب تصديرها الى الخارج هذا ليس
اسمه تصدير هذا اسمه تهريب ثروت وسياده
الدوله عندما تفقد الذهب الذهب في البنك
المركزي جزء من الارهاب جزء منها الربع
الى لبنان هذه كلها تؤكد لك ان هذا النظام
بدا في مرحله ما فيه
يعني بشار الاسد
في شهر رمضان اراد حتى ان
يعني اصدر مرسوم سماه صندوق الزكاه
والصدقات يعني ما بس حتى بيسرق منها ام
المواطن العادي حتى اذا كان
فيه
اموال الصندوق من اموال الدوله العامه
يعني
حتى قضيه انه
عم تشتغل
ايضا بدو يشارك شركات خاصه
شركات امنيه بتنافس الاخرين والسوق
سلطانيه عقليه وقاطع طريق اصبحنا فعليا
امام اقتصاديه اقتصاد في حاله من الفقر لا
عمل الاسعار غاليه كل شيء غير متوفر
اقتصاد اقتصاد
هذا فيه مزايا لكل من يسمون فينا نصفهم ب
ب ب امراء الحرب الذين يحتكرون الاستيراد
السري ويبيعونها باسعار عاليه
تقول صحيفه الاخبار التابع لحزب الله ليست
نحن
بتقول انه يتولى هذه ال ما فيه تتولى لجان
بالعمل الوطني شعارات وتحت كل المواد
الغذائيه و تتعمد رفع الاسعار
حلب الشعب السوري بتقول انه هو تتساءل
الصحيفه
المقال في كتاب دفاعا عن قدري جميل
اسمع السؤال الم يسمع من بيده الامر في
سوريا هلا للاسف
الرئيس لم يطلعوا به الاسد وعصابته على
سبيل المثال لانه
عملوا لك على سبيل المثال لماذا لم يتحدث
احد لردع ه هل بقاء هذا الرجل وامثاله في
الشارع اهم من سوريا سوريا طبعا بالنسبه
هذا
[موسيقى]
النظام
معارضه
خمسه خمسه وثلاثين العامل الى الوراء
سوريا
خمسه وثلاثين سنه
انه فيه اربعين سنه فيها البلد
هذا النظام بدون دمار
اللي هو موقع حكومه تابعه للمخابرات
السوريه يقول لك بالحرف الواحد ان سوريا
عادت سته وثلاثين سنه الى الوراء والبعض
الاخر موقع سوريا تقول لسوريا بحاجه
بحاجه ل خمسين سنه كي نعود الى الاقتصاد
السيئ الذي كان في سوريا الثوره
يا اخي عندما النظام يقول لك البنيه
التحتيه في سوريا
اقتصادي
اسبوع
بريطانيا
الشعب السوري
الشباب اللي موجوده
كيف ترد على
الان بالرغم من الوضع الاقتصادي المصري
بالنسبه للمواطن السوري الذي اصبح على
الحديث بالمناسبه الجوع ينتقل من بيت الى
بيت في سوريا في كل المحافظات
طب انت انت لا تؤمنون بكل الاحصائيه طيب
لماذا فرض ضرائب على الشعب السوري
ضريبه مجهود حربي يعني لماذا يريد هذا
النظام الذي دمر البلد على الشعب السوري
ان ياخذ هذا الشعب اللي
الاقتصادي الموضوع ان يؤمن بالشعب السوري
الشعب السوري
الشعب السوري اكبر من
ومشكله السوريه الاقتصاديه هذا المشاهد
بالنسبه
الشعب السوري خرج ثوره حريه وكرامه
بالصواريخ استخدم السلاح سلاح والان
النظام يحاول ان
ولكن لا يعلم انه
من يحاول ان هذا الشعب العظيم
هناك فرق كبير الشعب كرامه ولكن هناك من
يقوم هذا النظام عندما تقوم بكل هذه
الاعمال عندما تنافس المواطن على لقمه
عيشه عندما
المعارضه المعارضه
ليش الغذائي على على حل
الشعب
في العالم في العالم من يدعي انه هو
يستطيعون ان الشعب السوري
على المعارضه
[ضحك]
ولن يبقى ولم يبقى
اخر عبقريات النظام الاجراميه يريد ان
يقدم بطاقات تموينيه البطاقات التموينيه
في كل دول العالم تقدم عندما يكون نسبه
الفقر تحت ثلاثين بالمائه فانت
الله
مدرسه حزب البعث
التموين بطاقات التموين عندما تريد ان
تقدمها هم يريدون ان يستخدموها اسيره
للابتزاز يقدمون لفات الشبيحه ومن ولونا
لهم ويحرمون المناطق ال ال المحرره
والمناطق التي يدعون انهم لا يريدون ان
يحاسب يدعون المعارضه انه
هذا اليوم
ال ليله البارحه واليوم اضطر الثوار في
الغوطه الشرقيه ان يدخلوا على ما على
المطاحن الرسميه يفك الحصار عنها ملايين
من الناس دخلوا الى المطاحن واخذها عنوه
على النظام عندما
الشعب ياخذ
ياخذ حقوقه في قواتها لقمه العيش
اصبحت موضوعه بد من الشعب السوري وهذه
بفضل صواريخ كم وهذه بفضل قيادتكم المؤتمر
منذ
الى الحكم يعني
لم تاتي من بلحظه هذه جاءت من نظام عمرو
اربعين سنه عندما
استخدم اقتصاد الاقتصاد الحرب واقتصاد
المحتل الذين هدفه الاساسي تدمير البنيه
التحتيه اكبر من يمكن في اقل وقت ممكن من
الزمن في حال حدوث الانقلاب عليها اوغلو
سوريا كانت قبل ان ياتي مش حافظ الاسد
كانت الجامعات الاولى في العالم العربي
الاولى في العالم العربي البنك المركزي
السوري
في هذه الاجواء التي تطورت ما يسمى الان
بامتياز
ليس فقط على المناطق المحرره المناطق الان
بدؤوا
هذا النظام
المواطن
بالنسبه لهذا النظام الذي يعلم ان
انه يعني هناك الان
في سوريا اصبحوا الحرب
[موسيقى]